you we're gonna let you get out of the
commentator for the olympics how was
that any like cool stories from that
what's up village like is it [ __ ] fest i
heard it i did not go to the village
because of the covered restrictions
basically i had to only be in my hotel
yeah or at the venue and there was an
app you had to install that tracks your
movements yeah that's called a wife
that's the app
it was full-on um but i but also i
i felt very lucky to be there because
the skaters their families couldn't even
go watch yeah there's no spectators yeah
and i'm just free roaming
yeah i mean i went i went to the venue i
was
pretty much the first one to skate the
park course no
yeah because the park skaters weren't
there yet they were coming in the next
day because everybody comes in for their
event and then you go they're not there
for you so i came in and the street the
street area is right next to the park
and i roll in with my skateboard and i'm
like oh i'm getting it
just go in and start scanning it was
more about asking forgiveness and
permission at that point yeah i did get
kicked off the street course though no
yeah somebody had to kick tony hawk yeah
it was funny the announcer came over
because
i was shooting
i was shooting the warm up and i was
doing like
you could you could stand on the side
and shoot video um but i was actually
following people
through the chorus
but with their permission the skaters
yeah but then at some point
someone saw me on the camera it went up
to the tower
what the [ __ ] he doing so who's the
guy that has the dude it was it was this
uh french dude that was doing the
announcing just for the venue yeah
please get off
i
i'm sorry i didn't want to say that
i get kicked out stuff all the time
mark well i'm curious two things one uh
how was the experience of skating with
your kids like once they were able to
skate and you were talking about
encourage them to all of our kids skate
yeah wow in fact
when we go travel the first order of
business is finding the skate parks in
the area not because i want
right because they want to and then i
just become their filmer
yeah yeah that is absolutely dynamic
yeah how we how we travel
um
even here like when when sabrine built
the ball in brooklyn
as soon as we got to york they're like
can we just get the can you see it
supreme like i guess i'll find out who
runs the place
um and uh
i think the fun thing for me is that
not everyone but so many people skate
now that it's more common that they do
that they don't
and so to see them living in an era
where it's like all their friends skate
or they know skating or they're down
with it is really fun
[Laughter]
most of them are out of the house now
but when they were living there and
their friends come over who all skate
too
they'd all be downstairs like arguing
about the origins of some trick
name and this i come into the kitchen
like
to get a drink or something and i'm just
like
you guys want the answer
[Laughter]
i was there
when it happened i named it
that's you
and they're just like i'm just that yeah
they're like
wow that's wild don't give us your
tell us about your old school stuff yeah
you okay guys are you amongst yourselves
i'll see you later do they play the
games do they like them
um yeah yeah for sure
more like my son riley he's uh 28 now
but he grew up in the era of teaching
then eventually became a character in it
um because he's a pro skater but uh but
he was more of that era and then when
the when the remaster came out um
last year uh
i have i had one but basically another
one now off of what mark said uh about
skating with your kids is there an age
where you're like
i think i need to stop skating i have a
number in my mind or anything are you
just going to skate i never made those
ultimatums so they just felt like
backfires
okay um i feel like if i'm able to stand
on my own two feet i'll ride a
skateboard right it might not be on the
level that people
expect right and maybe i won't do the
public
but i can't stay on you can not skate
yeah i mean at this point
i'm just enjoying because i i have found
this sort of new
um
this new approach to skating where i can
do new tricks and they're not high
impact
more technical and they're really more
for
the only people who appreciate them are
skaters themselves yeah the most part
yeah your last video you posted i didn't
even know what happened
[Laughter]
it's like that and so i i really enjoy
that creative process right and that's
what's keeping me fired up um
and if i can't you know if i if i don't
feel like i'm being innovative or i'm
not really
i'm not living up to the ideals of a pro
skater then i won't do it in public yeah
but for now
i'm so good at it
i have a
i have a question we're uh well myself
akash and mark are all stand-ups
uh we're very lucky we get to make
living doing something we love uh
something we're trying to improve at
constantly it's creative endeavor it's
really fun it's exciting um
i'm curious
if if maybe you can give us some advice
some things to make sure we don't miss
out on because right now we're in that
heyday right well some of us are a
different stage of a career mark is is
younger in the game but like what are
the things that you look back on you're
like oh i really wish i kind of sat and
appreciated that or
um
for sure the camaraderie because i was
so hyper focused on competition
that i kind of missed
what was what else was happening and and
the friendships that were made
and
maybe i just ignored it for the most
part
this is the ball yeah and i see how many
people made these
incredible friendships along the way and
have these memories and i was like what
where was that i didn't i don't remember
that
um but also the the travel i
for me when i was
when i was young
i was this kid from san diego
i never traveled anywhere
and so when i would go places it was
just weird that weird food
experience
and i and i didn't appreciate that this
is something to
to revel in yeah i can't believe i have
these experiences now i absolutely
embrace it but back then i didn't and i
feel like i
would have had a deeper appreciation for
my experience but
really embrace europe or really embrace
japan yeah i do now but but in those
days it just felt
[Applause]
you